[Aplausos]
olá
cíntia matos moradora da baixada
fluminense
nascida e criada nesse território
composto de 13 municípios de educação de
arte de cultura de gentes onde vivenciei
minha infância e juventude momentos que
eu jamais esquecerei e hoje ainda moro
neste território
aos 40 anos de idade mas agora quero
contar um pouquinho pra vocês de quem é
o sul educadora popular pedagoga
trabalho com rodas de conversa com
mulheres e meninas de favelas e
periferias da metropolitana do rio de
janeiro
é um desafio no ano de 2011 perco minha
avó dona diva uma referência feminina
pra mim e lembrar da minha avó é lembrar
de quando ela contava histórias pra mim
e pra minha irmã momentos que eu jamais
esquecerei pensar na minha avó é lembrar
de coisas simples como simples fato de
fazer um arroz
isso mesmo fazer um arroz tinha toda uma
metodologia a água precisava está bem
servida
o arroz bem refogado e o encontro dos
dois faziam barulho aí sim estava na
hora de fechar a panela
sou voluntária numa biblioteca lá no
parque paulista em duque de caxias que é
o gta grupo de angélica onde sou
voluntária e desenvolva um projeto
chamado horto técnicas são ordens em
espaços de bibliotecas comunitárias que
tem como objetivo implantar junto a
escolher juntas e comer juntas e com
esse projeto eu fui selecionada para ir
para londres
imagina eu em londres
fomos nove jovens de favelas e
periferias
lá nós tivemos dez dias de vivências
intensas e choque de realidade
ao chegar ao aeroporto a minha primeira
atitude foi colocar o passaporte entre a
calça e casaco o celular no peito coisas
que já faço aqui na baixada aqui no
brasil mas a menina que me recebeu olhou
assim meio estranho falou que está
fazendo isso eu meia sem graça foi
colocando todas as coisas de volta na
bolsa e seguimos o trajeto do aeroporto
até o rosto
tudo aquilo me fascinava muito aquelas
casas que eu só via em filme e eu ali
estava
ao retornar para o meu país receba uma
enxurrada de informações
logo no primeiro dia perdemos uma mãe e
uma filha pela violência urbana em um
morro carioca
uma mulher que estava grávida perdeu seu
bebê
isso tudo acontece em duque de caxias na
baixada fluminense
fiquei pensando nisso tudo durante um
tempo foi quando eu tive a idéia de
pegar duas cadeiras de praia
escuto histórias numa tentativa de
travar zhar de não pensar em nada mas
para minha surpresa lá na praça
apareceram 12 pessoas e foram essas
pessoas que me resgataram elas contar as
suas histórias e quando retorna para
casa
aquelas histórias ainda estavam em mim
ligou para uma amiga aline e relato tudo
que havia acontecido naquela manhã
choramos nos emocionamos sorrimos
conversamos durante uma semana e durante
essas conversas ela fala pra mim porque
na sua próxima roda de conversa que você
faz com as meninas e com as mulheres
você não faz um produto e aí fiquei
pensando o que eu poderia fazer
eternizar os próximos de momento já que
ele não foi possível
pensei em fazer uma colcha de retalho
uma coxa de memórias afetivas aonde cada
pessoa
um pedacinho de tecido e nesse tecido eu
distribuo linhas agulhas afectos cada
uma desenha e cada uma borda e se elas
não souberem a gente borda juntas pensar
nessa coxa é pensar numa sociedade mais
justa igualitária pensar que juntas
podemos transformar uma sociedade porque
nós precisamos da escuta ativa
é isso que eu acredito
então quando eu retorno quando o retorno
para casa e pega essa coxa em tela lado
o arroz é inevitável não pensar ela
volta para dentro de mim
resgatar as memórias afetivas é um
momento jantam resgatar as memórias
afetivas é o momento de empatia de
conectar se consigo mesmo
então é inevitável que não que nós
possamos fazer essa conexão do passado
do presente e do futuro
percorro praças e lugares da cidade do
rio de janeiro e da baixada fluminense
procurando pessoas que queiram dividir a
sua história junto comigo lembrem do meu
quadro escuto histórias vêm aumentar as
da coxa coletiva comigo
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]